Paul what's your take care you know you
nailed it I mean this is the issue right
it's this fundamental tension between
privacy and law enforcement in the limit
of privacy we can't enforce the law and
the limit of law enforcement you can't
enforce privacy but I think so Apple
made the argument had made but Islands
honestly I thought the arguments it made
were fairly weak I mean it's heavily
reliant on a 1994 law called the
communication insistence for law
enforcement act Kalia which was really
not very much revised since then a lot
it didn't anticipate the rise of things
like like iphones for specifically you
know devices where you could store so
much information and so by relying on it
what they're implicitly saying is that
you can kind of create this zone of
almost extra legality built around
iPhones because because they were too
anticipated I can hide anything I want
there and from a law enforcement
standpoint and probably from a broader
societal standpoint that's just not
acceptable so you know I think in the
end Apple is gonna be forced to give way
and these arguments aren't going to
matter very much yep all it strikes me
having read the pleading that an awful
lot of it was this is going to be really
really hard it's going to take a lot of
people and time and from a company of
apples size and resources I'm wonder if
the judge's ruling to be that
sympathetic yeah and further honestly
they could have made it sound a lot
harder or they said something like you
know well this could take ten engineers
two three four weeks and it's like well
you know what if that's all it's going
to take I'm not that hung up about it
that's one of the arguments that people
were making here is saying Apple doesn't
even know if it can do this it may take
a very long time an apple concedes in
its in its motion that actually it's
probably something like 10 engineers in
four weeks and I don't think the judge
will be swayed by that at all and I
found one of their other arguments not
to get too deep into legal pleadings
really mischievous this First Amendment
argument that the courts can't compel
apple to write software because that's
cos software is is is free is free
speech and the course can't compel that
without violating can can't compel
speech without violating the First
Amendment that's extremely mischievous
argument because in the limit what
happens whenever we have other software
and we run on software as a society
that's causing safety or security issues
and you know we can't compel
manufacturers to recall cars and fix
software that's causing problems on the
roads come on be serious all right well
you
say they're mischievious Michael Hayden
is actually signing with Apple take a
listen on the general principle the
general principle being the FBI
directors and others requirement demand
requests that Apple universally enable
back doors in all of their devices to
break otherwise unbreakable encryption
that on that one I actually side with
Apple so there you go former CIA
director siding with Apple what do you
make of that Paul yeah and I mean this
that's essentially the arguing people
are making that if you put in a backdoor
it has unanticipated consequences and
this term back door is heavily freighted
in the technology community is some kind
of bogeyman that's deeply you know
troubling and mysterious and everything
else and I think that's the mistake is
to introduce that term of backdoor we're
not talking specifically some kind of
backdoor that's almost like a feature
you know along with pinch screen your
type pensions and zoom you get a back
door on an apple iphone as a new release
in the next version of the software this
isn't what we're talking about it an
apple or FBI is even gone so far as to
say you know we'll hold on to the phones
and you can do whatever you want to do
with it just let us send codes to it so
we can try and unlock the phone this
isn't about some sort of you know
wide-scale product release that
introduces the feature otherwise known
as back door I think that's a bit of
sofas tree Paul I have one question is
the bad news good news three months ago
or we were talking about is the prospect
of a decline in smartphone sales now Tim
Cook has got this pasted everywhere no
one's talking about the actual business
anymore are they know they're not you
know and actually that's a really great
point this is this is a really in a
sense in the long run is a sideshow and
it reflects the you know the incredible
importance of smartphones and these
sorts of peripheral devices like this
and as no bearing in the long run on the
business because this is an issue all
manufacturers face it's not unique to
Apple so Paul this is very quick and
unfair Apple loses what happens to the
stock price what happens to a stock
price the next day honestly nothing I
think the certainty is much more
important than whatever issues from loss
in the courts here though thank you very
much as Palka droski joining us